[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec françoischemeck
directeur de la Mission Locale Skyway 16
25 Owen Bardell et Jonathan Barclay vous
êtes tous les deux bénéficiaires du
dispositif contrat engagement jeune
bonjour à tous les trois bonjour Alors
Françoise on va commencer par vous la
mission locale est présente sur tout le
territoire de 50 ans en Yvelines vous
aider et accompagner les jeunes de 16 à
25 ans dans l'insertion professionnelle
à trouver leur voie comment se passe
justement l'accompagnement d'un jeune à
la Mission Locale quels sont les
différentes étapes donc la méfiant
lequel accueille les jeunes qui ont
quitté le système scolaire ils ont fini
leurs études et à partir de là on les
accompagne dans leur insertion sociale
et professionnelle c'est à la fois le
travail sur le projet professionnel la
recherche de formation la recherche
d'emploi mais ces jeunes ils vont aussi
être confrontés à une recherche de
logement à un moment ou un autre ils
peuvent avoir des difficultés
financières ils savent pas forcément
faire comment faire par rapport à la
prise en charge de leur santé etc donc
tous les tous les volets de leur vie de
jeune adulte alors justement à partir du
moment où il pousse les portes de la
Mission Locale donc vous d'abord vous
définissez ensemble leur besoin leurs
envies oui donc ils auront attribué
toujours le même conseillé parce que on
pense qu'il est très important qui est
un lien qui se crée une connaissance
mutuelle et
les jeunes apprécient habite
habituellement ça voilà en face de
quelqu'un qui le connaisse à partir de
là il va y avoir plusieurs entretiens on
va dire de diagnostic et puis on va
essayer de construire ensemble ce
diagnostic de l'élaborer ensemble ce
diagnostic et de construire un plan
d'action si vous les accompagnez donc
pour trouver une formation ou un emploi
et vous l'avez évoqué vous proposez
également un accompagnement dans les
démarches sociales comme la santé le
logement les aides financières ou encore
la mobilité pourquoi ces aides
sont-elles essentielles pour pour la
jeunesse parce que pour la jeunesse
comme pour tout le monde tout est aussi
lié par exemple sans logement stable
difficile d'avoir une stabilité
profession
si on n'a pas résolu des problèmes de
santé
dans une recherche d'emploi n'est pas
simple donc
souvent ils n'ont pas une partie de nos
jeunes n'ont pas en interne dans leur
famille les ressources qui vont pouvoir
les aider à faire face à ces situations
et vous proposer également le contrat
engagement jeune alors qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que c'est en effet donc
l'émission locale met en oeuvre les
politiques publiques parmi celles-ci
l'État a mis en oeuvre il y a un peu
plus d'un an le contrat engagement jeune
on va dire il a un peu pris la
succession de la garantie jeune après un
bilan des points positifs et point moins
positifs pour donc une formule un peu
rénovée c'est un contrat qui va durer 6
mois l'état confié la mise en oeuvre du
coup l'État a confié la mise en œuvre du
contrat engagement jeune à la fois Pôle
emploi et aux missions locales les deux
opérateurs du service public de l'emploi
le mettent en œuvre donc ça va être un
contrat de 6 mois qui s'adresse à tout
jeune il n'y a pas de conditions de
niveau scolaire pas de conditions de
ressources pas de conditions d'habiter
en qpv voilà tout jeune déscolarisé bien
sûr et pendant ce temps-là on va essayer
de le mobiliser de l'accompagner de
façon intensive vers l'emploi ou la
recherche d'un contrat d'alternance ce
sont les deux objectifs du contrat
engagement jeune alors pour pour résumer
c'est donc un dispositif qui a pour
évoqué Sion donc d'aider les jeunes qui
ne sont pas étudiants ou ne suivent pas
une fin de suivre aucune formation
professionnelle c'est un parcours vous
l'avez dit qu'il se fait en 6 ou 12 mois
qu'est-ce que vous faites justement avec
ces jeunes pendant pendant cette période
alors on va essayer de créer une
dynamique de groupe pendant deux mois ou
pendant ces deux mois on va leur
proposer environ sur la base d'un
mi-temps des ateliers toutes les
semaines à la Mission Locale ces
ateliers ils vont être très très variés
alors il va y avoir tout ce qui va
travailler tout ce qui va concerner la
recherche d'emploi un travail sur le
projet avoir les outils de recherche
d'emploi CV lettre de motivation
préparation entretien d'embauche
[Musique]
de mon conseiller Mission Locale
donc
quand nous commençons à parler c'était
en cours enfin c'était encore assez
vague sur ce que c'était
j'ai tenté l'aventure et du coup depuis
je depuis
juillet ou juin dernier
je suis dans ce J et qu'est-ce que ça
vous a permis justement qu'est-ce que
vous avez fait comme comme mission
peut-être pendant pendant ce dispositif
ça m'a alors bah du coup comme dit
François
j'ai pu
j'ai pu faire des ateliers qui m'a
permis de travailler par exemple mon CV
sur quoi j'avais des difficultés avant
d'être de motivation
ça m'a permis ensuite de mieux affirmer
mes recherches comment
prouver les sites pour trouver un emploi
ce dont j'avais du mal à faire avant
ça m'a aussi permis de motivé à faire ça
j'ai pu
faire un contrat chez dans une
entreprise donc plus le choix
et là je suis encore en cours de
recherche car mon contrat s'est terminé
mais avec le CJ bah je peux aujourd'hui
mieux chercher que il y a six mois alors
pour vous Jonathan comment est-ce que
vous avez connu justement le CEJ alors
moi la CSJ j'ai connu ça avec ma famille
d'accueil
ma famille d'accueil qui m'en avait
parlé qui m'avait dit que pour moi que
ce serait était le meilleur la meilleure
chose à faire pour découvrir peut-être
d'autres centres d'intérêt et découvrir
même des choses qui peuvent plus
m'approcher de ce que je veux faire
parce que j'ai toujours voulu travailler
dans l'audiovisuel
et du coup on m'a conseillé d'aller
là-bas parce que ça m'offrirait plus de
portes ça m'ouvrait plus d'occasions du
coup j'ai tenté l'expérience et là ça
fait du coup deux mois
où j'y suis donc pour vraiment ouais
j'ai fait par les ateliers
comme je disais François des ateliers
pour la confiance en soi pour le fait de
parler même le pour la sécurité web etc
et ben honnêtement ouais je
regarde des bons souvenirs parce que
c'est des choses qui m'ont servi pour de
vrai et qui me serviront sur et certains
pour plus tard vous l'avez dit tous les
deux finalement ce CEG on a l'impression
qu'il permet aussi d'acquérir plusieurs
compétences et de découvrir plusieurs
plusieurs métiers mais dans votre dans
votre domaine c'est ça justement que
vous recherchiez à travers le CEJ
oui alors moi pour le coup je suis
quelqu'un qui aime beaucoup découvrir de
nouvelles choses et essayer d'agrandir
un maximum les possibilités que je peux
avoir et même les gens que je peux
rencontrer
et honnêtement je dois avouer qu'avec le
le
CVJ en fait dès le premier atelier on a
eu un atelier sur trois jours avec une
intervenante qui nous parlait de
pouvoir déterminer à peu près qui on est
nous connaître un peu mieux prendre le
temps aussi de méditer etc des choses
que on accorde pas forcément beaucoup
d'attention dans la dans la vie de tous
les jours honnêtement
dès la fin de ce premier atelier j'ai
compris que c'était ce genre de choses
qui me fallait en fait découvrir et tout
et du coup sur deux mois j'ai eu
l'occasion de découvrir énormément
d'ateliers énormément d'endroits et
aussi beaucoup de gens qui ont aussi
beaucoup d'histoires et c'est
honnêtement moi c'est la chose que j'ai
préféré en fait parce que c'était c'est
des choses dont j'avais besoin et quel
est votre votre parcours enfin votre
projet professionnel alors comme je vous
l'ai dit j'ai envie de bosser dans
l'audiovisuel alors en fait et c'est là
où il y a beaucoup de de conflits dans
ma tête c'est que d'un côté la régie
m'intéresse beaucoup il y a aussi le
côté
de metteur en scène etc et de cadrage
c'est des choses qui ont beaucoup
intéressé et du coup aussi c'est aussi
le but quelque part aussi que je
recherche en faisant
en faisant le CJ c'est de pouvoir me
focus sur une seule chose en fait
arriver vraiment à me décider quoi et
ben en vrai j'avance et pour vous ouais
pour la finalité moi aussi j'ai
l'impression d'avancer enfin j'avance ça
c'est sûr en fait c'est pas juste une
impression et alors moi niveau parcours
c'est ça a été de base je partais dans
le jeu vidéo je me disais j'allais dans
le jeu vidéo
finalement
[Musique]
j'ai abandonné le jeu vidéo et à partir
de ce moment là c'est vrai qu'il y a une
grosse période où je ne savais plus quoi
faire du tout
et avec le CEJ j'ai pu découvrir le
métier de la vente auquel je me serais
jamais dit tiens ça pourrait
m'intéresser finalement ça m'a
super plu ce dont je pensais pas et pour
le moment j'essaie de rester dans le
métier de la vente surtout de produits
culturel
voir
livre je veux tout ça et par la suite
j'ai encore des doutes sur ce que je
veux faire
parce que j'ai encore plein d'idées en
tête mais c'est vrai que bah avec le CEJ
ça me permet aussi de voir ce que je
peux faire vous avez compétences que
j'ai voilà vous avez l'occasion de toute
façon de retester encore d'autres
domaines merci beaucoup à tous les trois
d'avoir répondu à nos questions pour
plus d'informations on peut se rendre
sur le site Skyway 165.fr et pour revoir
ou réécouter cette émission rendez-vous
sur notre site et notre application
radio sensation
[Musique]